I'm sorry there's a very there's a big
difference between the people who are
telling people go out and get fat versus
AO who's saying accept me the way I am
she's not just saying accept me the way
I am she's dressing extremely scantily
clad and then saying if you don't think
that it's normal for a morbidly obese
person to be wearing a g- string in the
middle of public then you're the
problem being fat or skinny
is a choice
agers of course not every factor is
purely Choice um I don't think that
every factor is but I do think a
majority of it is and in most cases for
most people being skinny or being fat um
is about willpower it's about um the
environment you grow up in sure but who
you choose to associate with what sort
of things you choose to listen to who
you choose to kind of have as your
friends around you and support you all
of those things are choices that you can
make that will lead you closer towards
being one or the other I know what I do
with my body I know what I put into it
day in and day out I choose not to eat
some days um I Choose You know how I
want to look and I don't fault anyone
for how they want to look or how they
want to be but I think it's a choice at
the end of the day I'm very you know
always wish-wash on I want to be
presented and if I want to gain weight
or not but the only person that's going
to gain the weight at the end of the day
is me and me myself for me it's calories
in calories out go to the gym you'll get
buff don't go to the gym you won't get
buffed I understand that there's
genetics that could cause you to want to
eat more but even with the genetics that
cause you to want to eat more the same
solution is calories and calories out I
think the the whole choice is you know
always determined on who they are and
it's not going to just be be a thing
done overnight it takes a lot of I think
it's like Breaking the Barrier and
breaking a lot of things not only your
body but also breaking your mental state
sure and again that depends on who you
are and what you want to go through
disagree
your I felt like as a toddler I always
viewed myself as big I grew up in a very
like poor home so where my mom couldn't
provide the meals that she could
healthily so when we would get like free
meals even then it would be like canned
food and it would be like very much food
that's not as edible it was food for us
yes but then I felt like once it reached
a point where I was old enough to try to
make my own choices I made all of the
wrong choices I wasn't eating and I was
only eating like grapes and lettuce and
that was mainly because I was in a sport
and that sport just worked me out so
hard and it was to the point where I
just was scared to eat I I didn't like
it I would only drink water when you
were eating grapes and lettuce were you
thin I was the thinnest I could be were
you still big though I I was still big
but that was the skinniest I've ever
been and that's coming from somebody who
was only eating somewhat salads that are
just fruit and lettuce and water and
maybe ice right before a practice do you
think that right now you would not be
capable of becoming a thin woman if you
wanted I possibly would be capable of
becoming a thin woman but since I was
young I was supposed to get blood tested
probably when I was very very young and
I never did and they had mentioned that
it could have been because of my weight
and how that connects with my thyroid I
never made the connection and I never
had like that like leaning parent to be
like go and get checked out go and do
this like your weight is probably not
your fault it was always like your
weight is your fault so that's your
issue I mean I also struggle with you
know thyroid and my own blood issues I'm
not quite sure but I do see an
endocrinologist and I go see a doctor
it's a choice to do the requisite steps
it's a choice to go grocery shopping
instead of going to fast food when it's
easy it's a choice when you're grocery
shopping to go to the outer aisles and
like not go into the bread section and
not go into the junk food section these
are all choices as a disabled woman I
can't do a lot of the things that people
say calories in calories out oh you got
to go work out and exert it a lot of the
things that are typical oh this is how
you lose weight put me in the hospital I
have to navigate weight differently I
have to look at it differently my weight
is the way it is because of medication
because doctors put me in this position
and I had to learn okay am I going to be
so hateful of my own body that I am
going to backlash and put myself through
extreme gym nights through keeping
myself from eating things that I should
be able to eat you should be able to
have a balance you should be able to go
into the junk food aisle like other
skinny people do and still not have to
worry about gaining 20 lbs but I don't
think skinny people go into this junk
food aisle certainly they eat a lot of
junk food a lot of junk I mean my door
Dash would tell you otherwise like
there's a thing called set points
there's a ton of research on it that
your body likes to be at specific
weights it likes to be in a specific way
so if you are fighting yourself to lose
weight by not eating OV exercising and
you are damn near killing yourself to be
at a specific weight your body's unhappy
it's important to not note that a choice
can be harder for people to make due to
conditions in their life but at the end
of the day it's still a choice I could
say that I had food addiction I looked
to food when I was stressed and this and
that and this and so it's harder for me
to choose it than for someone who has
like the perfect lifestyle who someone
who has parents who are giving them this
and that and this but I definitely still
acknowledge that it was my choice at the
end of the day when I go there and I
look and I see H should I order a second
hamburger I'm the one choosing whether
or not I order that second hamburger I'm
the one making that
choice hey you all right right I don't
know I've been feeling kind of lost
lately and how is this helping well I
don't know to be honest I'm just trying
to figure out who I am well I don't want
to hold you back with what works you
might have a breakthrough if you stare
long enough but if you want to talk to
someone about how you're feeling you
should check out better help the sponsor
of today's video with better help
finding a therapist is easy regardless
of limited options in your area so you
can get the proper help that you need
and it's super convenient cuz it's
online and remote oh nice I just filled
out a few questions and it says I'll be
matched with a professional therapist in
as little as a few days whether you're
going through a hard time or you want to
address a clinical mental health issue
therapy can give you great tools to
approach life in a different way so if
you're struggling consider online
therapy with betterhelp for 10% off your
first month of betterhelp click the link
in the description or visit
betterhelp.com juile media thanks
betterhelp for supporting this channel
now let's get back into the episode I
would rather be skinny than fat can the
agre please step
forward I think there's a lot of
different struggles when it comes to
being a bit
bigger and I have a sister that is very
like she's 400 lb and she struggles a
lot she has lymphadema and the to shower
is really really hard hard so I do think
for like an overall happy life and like
zero struggle I think I'd rather be
skinny I think that it is common in
society to want to be skinny I think the
average person typically wants to be
skinny I'm actually surprised that I
didn't see more people come forward on
that question people treat you better um
it is what is considered the standard of
beauty your life expectancy is is longer
you tend to be healthier I'm also really
tall I'm 6'6 so I kind of wish I uh
could just pick a single struggle
because uh finding the clothes and
things like that when you're bigger both
ways can make it really hard so if I was
skinnier at least that's one less thing
I have to worry about but also I've got
uh two kids and a wife and I'm taking
care of them and as you pointed out I
definitely think that I'm at less health
risks if I'm a skinnier person if I'm a
healthier person in that capacity and I
would much rather be that so that I
could be around for my kids longer can
the disagre please step
forward I'm speaking as someone who
actually was a former smaller person and
I had the most body insecurities when I
was small I was constantly living in
fear of gaining weight and having people
tell me oh don't don't gain weight don't
do this make sure that your weight is
the same and once I finally gained
weight I realized that first off life
wasn't over I didn't feel any need to
not engage in life the previous way that
I had and the attention that I got was
different but even as a smaller person
you get negative attention and rather
than trying to control my body to avoid
that negative attention I would prefer
to address the situation as a society
make it more accessible for everybody to
where we aren't feeling like I have to
be a certain way that's normal in order
to be treated like a human being and
respect it if I could counter because I
was a bit bigger when I was younger and
that's when I was the most insecure I
would look in the mirror I did have
family members that were skinny but then
I had a family M that was much bigger
and just the way that I perceived myself
I hated it and I even became anorexic to
like not be vix I don't think skinny
always equates to being healthy exactly
absolutely uh I am fairly skinny I 65
I'm 140 pounds last time I checked and
I'm severely underweight and I I know
about this on a day-to-day basis that
being said I don't know where I'd want
to lean at a appropriate weight level
but I think it's important to understand
for some skinny people it's we're not
living a great life by any means and
sometimes I feel like that's always kind
of Lost in Translation when they see
someone who's really skinny I I guess it
depends on what you mean when you think
of the term skinny are you thinking of
just like an average weight person are
you thinking of how you are now I'm the
average weight for like women in America
so if we're talking about an average
like I'm going to be the closest if your
biggest priority is to be in a smaller
body you need to reassess your
priorities not focused on Health in the
immediate tie between skinniness and
health like you emphasized there is such
a gap between one the research because
the research has a huge fat phobic bias
in
and there has been research that shows
that they aren't even especially during
let's say and the correlation between
obesity they rushed through those
studies so fast because in society's
mind oh of course a fat person is going
to equal someone who's going to get sick
faster he's going to get sick easier it
was an easy jump so they didn't do all
of the testing that they were supposed
to do they didn't check their bias by
saying the study is biased you're saying
that the study didn't account for the
variable that obesity may also take
factor into it's just that there's so
many variables in humanity that these
pharmaceutical companies could only
account for so many during their trials
and that doesn't necessarily mean that
they're bias however if you want to talk
about bias and studies actually recently
we've been doing the opposite so for
instance a lot of our Studies have been
based on BMI and so we've been showing
that oh fat people aren't necessarily
extremely unhealthy if we look at people
with a certain
BMI however bodybuilders also have a
really high BMI and so they get counted
into that category so it wasn't until
very recently that they equated for that
mistake and it shows oh my goodness
being fat is actually extremely
unhealthy like way way more unhealthy
than we ever realized you can't gauge
Health by looking at somebody like none
of my health issues all of them at my
weight gain but I always get assumed oh
don't you want to be skinny so that you
don't have a cane anymore and you don't
feel the way you feel it's like no cuz I
have Lupus and I'm always going to feel
like this CRPS it's it's going to
deteriorate it's going to continue
America has an obesity
problem say next to you oh absolutely I
think it's pretty clear you look at the
weight of the average American you see
how obesity has affected not just
children I mean the fact that we have
more younger and younger people who are
looking heavier and heavier and you you
see that like you know the way that
weight affects us as a society and you
compare that to how we were in the past
now not not that we should always you
know we shouldn't compare ourselves to
the era of the Great Depression when
people just couldn't find food of course
but people are heavier now in an
unhealthy way and people have are eating
unhealthy they are eating it through
unhealthy access to food they're eating
diets high in seed oils they're eating
High corn syrup they're they're doing
all this kind of stuff that's not good
for them that we didn't used to do and
it's bad it's not a good thing it's an
epidemic it needs to be it needs to be
quashed in some capacity there's so much
access to
justun anything like it's so crazy these
days and you know I'm so surprised that
we're actually supporting a lot of this
you know and there's always people like
you know like it's fine that we have
like three McDonald's like on the same
street and it's just like we don't think
that this is adding to the problem what
I think is really sad about that is so
many people in America just see the
profit in it I don't want to say I know
that these people know the problem but
it's like how can you not see the
problem they have to see it and just not
care they have to just be like well
we're gaining profit do you see how much
this McDonald's is making put another
one across the street like that's just
like it that's the corporations it's the
medical industry having a fat country
makes us money it doesn't help that our
cities aren't walkable either America is
a country of non walkable that is why I
I wavered a little bit because I think
we have a problem with how to treat
obesity I think we have a problem with
how to make it so that it is not an
epidemic this is a systemic thing that
we are in a society and in an
environment that breeds this and we are
doing it to ourselves we are doing it to
our children and our corporations and
our Industries are doing it to us and
they aren't having to take
responsibility they're encouraging it
with media so and the mukbangs I was
literally going to bring that up the
mukbangs and like all those videos that
just come up to Trends not only the
mukbangs but also like lizo and other
big like
media I'm sorry there's a very there's a
big difference between the people who
are telling people go out and get fat
versus AO who's saying accept me the way
I am she's not just saying accept me the
way I am she's dressing extremely
scantily clad and then saying if you
don't think that it's normal for a
morbidly obese person to be wearing a g-
string in the middle of public then
you're the problem and they're trying to
normalize Society to this obese culture
which is extremely unhealthy and what is
an obese culture a culture which like
normalizes I haven't even heard that
obesity is already normal so it's I
don't think it should be normalized and
it has and it wasn't normal just a coule
what the difference between a obese
person myself walking around in a g-ring
or a bathing suit as I do almost every
day and a skinny person like is it okay
that the skinny person is doing that I
don't think so but that's Reas I get the
whole public thing to say that when lizo
does it is the same as a Victoria Secret
Angel is just not the same yeah what's
the difference what you mean are you
telling me they look you're telling me
it doesn't I'm not saying they look the
same I mean implication so if I walk
down the street I'm a runway model I'm a
print and runway model I have walked
down a runway in a thong so me doing
that is shameful but a skinny model is
okay I ne I don't know if I use the
phrase shameful I don't think that we as
a society should be modeling obesity but
I'm not modeling obesity I'm modeling
the lingerie that obese people need to
be able to have availability to buy so
they've always had the ability to buy we
have not you a single underwear is like
almost
$20 and you go to like any other w any
Target and like all these underwears are
in special for like5 to like $20 and
stuff well it does take more fabric to
make it it does take more fabric to make
it excuse but make yards of fabric for
gowns you like is a small a different
price than an extra large or a large for
three Exel shirts I got to pay more
money I think people view models and
Instagram people and all of us who are
plus- eyes and proud as we're pushing
this obese lifestyle no I'm pushing the
fact that this is what I live in this is
my life and I need other people who feel
this way to say hey I want to be able to
wear clothes that look cute
too I do think there's a problem with
obesity in America but I think it's a
first world country problem because it's
spread across the globe and also I don't
see it as a problem I do feel like
healthwise people should try to be
healthy but there's no perfect body
there's no perfect person there's no
perfect size and there's people who are
underweight there's a lot of them and
then there's a lot of people who are
overweight so I I really don't see it as
like a problem but just to touch on what
you were saying because I am in the
fashion industry I wanted to become a
fashion designer my dad was one and they
buy 10 rolls of fabric for one price so
it really doesn't cost that much to make
underwear sure but don't you have to
worry about distribution I mean if if
the average person is let's say in
between small medium large and you're
sending clothes out for those you know
you could send out 10,000 of this 10,000
of that 10,000 of that you can't always
send out 10,000 3XL because you're not
going to have that many people fitting
in the 3XL no because there's somebody
who works in marketing and they research
that that um area there's a census so we
have a database of what type of people
are there now we don't know who's going
in there but we know the type of people
that live in that area and the type of
the people that come and visit the area
so that person is doing their job
accordingly and usually large sizes are
sold out okay so somebody brought up the
food desert earlier I can't even think
of an area that would have a so-called
food desert sorry can someone explain
like maybe just for my ignorance I'm
guessing a food desert is just there's
no food anywhere no it's healthy options
for food so you can go into certain
lowincome areas and you'll see a
Starbucks a mcdal
a Chick-fil-A but there's no Trader
Joe's a food desert actually properly
there isn't any like for a long period
of driving there's one gas station and a
liquor store then you have to drive two
more miles to hit the next grocery store
but with the food desert it's not just
that there can be a grocery store there
but if I'm making minimum wage I'm not
going to spend all of my money on what
is going to last me two meals versus
what's going to last me an entire week
or if I'm on EBT and I have specific
things that I have to choose to buy
versus what I can't buy I'm barn and
raised in Colorado in the outskirts
there's so many small towns that you
don't even know that they're there you
most of them you won't see on a map but
if you're from there then you'll know
and they all have to drive a decent
amount to be able to go to an actual
grocery store but how often are you
going grocery shopping maybe like once
every two weeks would be typically
normal so you have to do a drive every
once a week so you're making a drive
once a week once every two weeks not a
lot of people access to the if I don't
have a car I don't and if you don't have
usually these food deserts also have
very poor public transportation options
so you are left with people who are
stranded yeah but then what are they
eating at all yeah unhealthy crap but
how are they surviving going through the
drivethru they don't got a car to go
exactly they usually what I seen when I
go to those rural towns and those rural
places is they have chickens and they
have animals and guess what that's you
can get some healthy food out of that
that's like you know having eggs and
protein and things like that I think I
would be healthier if I lived rly in
fact my wife and I are trying to leave
the state so we're not near all the Uber
Eats and all the I grew up in I grew up
in a town of 500 the Obesity problem
there was not as significant as say in
LA and we talk about like food deserts
and stuff the nearest Walmart where I
grew up was 45 minutes in any direction
the nearest McDonald's was nowhere near
to be seen for a long time so when I
hear these like and I you there could be
some evidence there as like the Obesity
problem is very low lift were there
grocery stores in your small town Yesa
like like I'm I I'm like kind of baffled
by the maybe I just need to go out there
and like experience the food deserts but
like there was grocery stores where I
grew up just because we lived in the
middle of nowhere doesn't mean we didn't
have access to food and actually and I
have to agree we did have access to
healthy food very healthy food all the
time I I I don't think this is a big of
an issue in my personal opinion fat
shaming is worse than skinny
shaming so I do agree that fat shaming
is worse than skinny shaming just
overall entirely the way that people
like comment on people's weight compared
to somebody's skinny they usually don't
comment on somebody's skinny they don't
think there's something wrong with them
they don't like they'll maybe say like
oh you're very thin and um do you want
to eat a cheeseburger but that's not as
bad as telling somebody you eat 10 stop
and you don't even know that they're
eating 10 fat shaming is a systemic
problem you're not going to not get a
job because you're too skinny skinny
bodies are praised in our society
whereas fat bodies like I don't get it
as often as other people but I get a lot
of comments on my Instagram that are
saying like you're really beautiful but
you would look a lot better if you lost
50 60 lbs
something that I always get a lot of
comments on is my masculinity as a man
because of how skinny I am it's always
something that I've always kind of dealt
with my favorite comment is always I
look like a a sickly ill Victorian child
and that's horrible sorry don't mean to
laugh at that no no no I don't it
doesn't bother me as much but this idea
that skinny people can't also feel get
get these kind of comments just kind of
mindblowing that doesn't mean that
they're you know that one side is
getting it worse than the other I think
that there are both sides getting piled
on just at different varying degrees I
think we're conflating two things as
well so there is a difference between
fat shaming and fat discrimination fat
shaming is an aspect of fat
discrimination but some of the things
you were touching on are specifically
societal and systemic fat discrimination
that goes into our medical system it
goes into employment it goes into all of
our civil rights as fat people people
that skinny people don't necessarily
have that same issue and I come from
cultures where they straight out called
out skinny people you look like bones oh
Flaka all like all of that so I watched
my cousins go through it I went through
it when I would get too skinny as people
we are just too scrutinized when it
comes to our bodies we don't let people
live but I think that's a good point you
said you were called Skin and Bones when
you got to my cousin what you're sorry
not whatever but your cousin so people
using shame as a motivator to get your
cousin to not be tooo skinny shame as a
motivator is a powerful tool so the
reason I sit over there is fat shaming
worse than skinny shaming well you could
argue that shaming somebody in order to
motivate them towards a healthy
lifestyle is actually a good thing now I
have a lot of empathy cuz hearing your
story about how you've been struggling
with this since you were a child since I
was like a newborn baby like Health just
everything's just been on that end where
I've never known anything about being
being skinny or being fit or being
athletic I've never known anything about
that probably your situation I don't
think shame necessarily would motivate
you but for somebody where it is a
option so for instance if you watch TLC
you watch my 600b life uh thousand pound
sisters family by the ton all of them
can do it all of them have had this
systemic issue that's the thing though I
have watched those like as a younger
person and it would make me feel
disgusted with me when I was a kid so it
would make me worse and it made my
mental health worse cuz then I'm like is
that how like everybody automatically
views me as just like somebody who's
oversized and could possibly never even
attain it cuz it's so just common I
don't think we should shame anyone to do
anything no I think everyone deserves to
like themselves enough to like enjoy
life and if you do that as a fat person
okay if you do it as a skinny person
also chill it's not my business sh is a
broad category I do think shame Works in
some cases I think that there has been
good fat shaming towards me and bad fat
shaming bad fat shaming is just you know
somebody just saying you're fat this
like that that doesn't really work but
what does work is somebody looking at me
and saying don't you want to be around
for your kids and that worked IED do you
consider that shaming I do I think
that's shaming I think they were telling
me like you should lose weight to be
around for your children I think that's
shame like like a an attempt to like try
and say something bad about me they're
personalizing toward you and towards
your kids like of course yeah it's yeah
but I think and I think that worked I
think that worked that really encouraged
me to go go to the gym and start trying
to lose weight that's you though sure I
think you have to be specific to the
person I think that's one thing is it it
depends on the person and if if someone
wants to shame me and like you know it
depends on the person I've been shamed a
couple times and it's kicked me in a
gear to try to gain weight but uh it's
still really hard and it's you know it
depends on who you are I think when you
were making a comment about people
questioning your masculinity
I get the question of actually looking
like a woman all the time and it's
always in play I always get compared to
like male characters especially when I
don't wear makeup and that's because I
don't have boobs and I can't help that
but it's definitely really really hard
to like have people tell you constantly
like here's the standard of how a woman
should look and you don't look like that
without even saying it they don't say it
they're categorizing me they're making
fun of me saying that I look like this
one soccer player or something and you
know I think it's funny but also shame
can also be hard cuz I I can see what
you mean sometimes it can really
motivate you when it's out of love but
when it's out of and when it's out of
like not knowing someone and just saying
it yeah the people who said that to me
about my kids were not yeah just I'm a
random guy online it was people who were
close to me and I knew cared about me
who I had conversation with so I do
think it it matters who says it but I
still would consider it to an extent
shaming um and I I'm okay with that I
think there is good shame I think that's
a I think sometimes it helps motivate
people pulling the right way the body
positivity movement promotes childhood
[Applause]
obesity diet culture has positive
effects I I guess for me Diet culture is
an important thing to have for people in
the world what I've realized after we're
about to finish this up is there wasn't
a lot of talk on skinny culture C people
as a whole maybe that's because of how
the prompt is but I think it's important
if we're going to give positivity to
kids who are obese I think it's
important to give them the options to
you know say if they want to lose weight
they can and I I don't see a problem
with that in any real
sense I think that diet culture is a
reason that a lot of people struggle
with weight problems in the first place
I have even struggled with my own weight
issues in the past and I was like
struggling kind of with depriving myself
too much because I had a trainer um and
then I started binge eating and as soon
as I had like a mental break where I was
like physically incapable of stopping
myself from putting food in my mouth I
immediately went to see a doctor and
that doctor told me to read a book
called intuitive eating and it wildly
changed my life and it was about getting
past diet culture and about how so many
people ruin their lives with diet
culture and you see it with like the
somebody talked about eating grapes and
lettuce and it's grapes and lettuce and
it's just like it's this extreme and so
you go from one extreme and then you
break and then you go to The Other
Extreme and so like I was in my extreme
I broke went so that's why I'm anti-diet
culture yeah I I tried keto for a while
um and and that's the thing about what I
realized is like that F that fad diet
kind of stuff and yeah did I lose weight
I Absol absolutely lost weight sure uh I
didn't keep it off and the reason I
didn't keep it off is because um diet
culture is about turning the word diet
from uh your your overall eating into um
an activity that takes place over a
period of time uh a diet it should not
be something you do from January until
May of next year diet is what you
continually eat is what you continually
put into yourself yeah lifestyle yeah so
my issue with diet culture is this idea
of like oh I've got this perfect
solution for you man all you got to do
is this this this and this and that and
it's like no like the the reality is is
like yeah there are good correct and
objective ways I think for a lot of
people to eat and yes everybody has to
have some variations here and there
there's no one bag fix all and diet
culture is so much about trying to say
like all you got to do is just eat
cheese puffs every day for the rest of
your life and it's easy yeah yeah and so
I just I that's why I think diet culture
doesn't help you know you're always
going to get those people who have the
perfect answer they have the perfect
solution to either lose weight or Diet
isn't just losing weight it's also
gaining weight you know and I think a
lot of people maybe it's just for me but
when I diet it's actually uh not the
opposite of fasting I'm trying to eat
more I'm trying to gain more and I think
people forget that when it comes to diet
when people instantly hear the word diet
they think losing weight and I don't
think that should always be the case
I've been on a lot of diets I've been on
diets for myself I've been on put on
diets and I've been put on diets by my
coaches so when I was young I felt like
it was more so like fasting fasting
fasting not eating but working out and
maybe hopefully eating once you get home
as a reward and then when it became like
oh like you're you're a good person in
the team to like be the big person be
the defender be buff so it was like now
we have to gain all this weight and we
have to pound you out so it was like I
had to eat like five meals in a day and
I was I felt so gross cuz I was just
like I've never had to like pull out
like a a bar or something and like eat
it during class and be like I have to
eat this cuz it's part of my diet when
we talk about diet culture we're talking
about not your diet as a whole it's
usually a fad diet is what we're talking
about when we're talking about diet
culture and for me personally I know
that I've seen a lot of especially women
in my life going on fat diets that are
just not sustainable and that's kind of
the purpose of diet culture is that it's
not a sustainable thing but we're all
talking about like mainstream like keto
like gluten-free and I I think it's
everyone's just polarize on these
certain ones that I believe that you
should eat gluten I think if you take it
out of your diet you're actually going
to get sick unless you're you are
unless no it goes back to like what she
said which is you know intuitive eating
so what is the positive you think you've
seen for people from diet culture which
I think and I guess what do you consider
diet culture I guess like Diet culture
to me is the resources you need to get
to where you want to be in your life in
your body that's how I've always view
diet by dieting do you mean like
journaling what you're eating yeah if
you want to journal if if you want to
you know talk to a therapist if you want
to work out if you want to see a doctor
if you want to go on meds like
everyone's always it's not being super
like when you diet you're not being like
I'm completely cutting out carbs or I'm
completely doing this right Dr water
only like watching your Macros and your
micros and you're calculating I guess if
if you're asking if I know how many
calories I have to eat yeah like I have
to eat like 4,000 a day when most people
talk about diet culture they've done
some sort of extremely restrictive thing
and when you do something really
restrictive it changes your brain
chemistry and the way that you think
about food and it makes you obsessive
over food and then like but it sounds
like the way that you're doing it is
extremely healthy because you're not
depriving your body of something but
isn't that just goes back to like you
guys are talking about the extremes of
diet culture diet culture is one thing
and then a healthy
lifestyle type are two different things
I personally don't think of
living a healthy lifestyle as a diet
you've been in like a model spheres do
do you see diet culture and how has it
impacted space there was a point in my
life like when I was a junior in high
school where the person that I was with
at the time he's like 6' six and super
tall and so you know the mom was like
Hey like my son is going to go audition
to this big agency which is still big to
this day and you know you should come so
I went and um I weighed 115 lbs and I
was a decup and they said that I weighed
too much and so seeing
that really struck me in the beginning
with the negative part of dieting and
just kind of went into the spiral of
like okay well if I'm too big then what
what are people doing to not be this
size like how how can I make it to be to
do what I want to do if this is my
limitation to it it took years later to
realize like I was really
disciplining myself for no apparent
reason except for this underlying
underlying feeling from years ago that I
could never get rid of when you're
talking about like discipline I think it
can be really positive with dieting and
like intaking your calories but for me
personally and I'm a very specific case
seeing those numbers and knowing that I
couldn't achieve it because I didn't
have the appetite was also just so
saddening to me because reading the bare
minimum of what a woman needs 5 five at
my age I was like that's not that much
and I still couldn't eat it at the time
and I'm like what's wrong with me
there's different ways to motivate
people and one of them is out of pain
and anger and I feel like a lot of the
diet culture whether it's for positive
or negative is just trying to gear into
that and you know I I just am more about
being healthy I I hear diet and I think
of something that's positive and it's
been positive to me and you know it's
something I'm always trying to achieve I
guess like if we were to do this the
same exact question I may hesitate and
not walk across the line uh I I guess
I'll never know but hearing these
perspectives were really good because I
probably didn't know as much about the
extremes I want to thank all of you for
sharing your opinions with us and for
challenging us and I I really want to
thank you I thank you for the back and
forth I it's something that I came here
for and I wanted to talk to somebody who
thinks differently and I've learned some
things so I appreciate that for all of
you than you yeah thank you this was
great it was RI cre